نقلت وكاله الانباء السوريه سنه وذلك في
خبر عاجل عن مصدر في قياده شرطه دمشق ان
قتلى وجرحى سقطوا جراء القصف الاسرائيلي
على احياء سكنيه في دمشق وهذه صور قد وصلت
قبل قليل
لدخان جراء القصف الاسرائيلي الذي استهدف
الاحياء السكنيه في العاصمه السوريه دمشق
والذي اوقع عددا كبيرا من القتلى والجرحى
[موسيقى]
وكانت وسائل اعلام رسميا سوريه قد قالت ان
اسرائيل قصفت اهدافا في محيط العاصمه
السوريه دمشق في ساعه متاخره من مساء امس
السبت الوكاله وكاله الانباء السوريه
تحدثت عن تصدي وسائل الدفاع الجوي لاهداف
معاديه في سماء العاصمه وهذه الصور التي
وردت قبل قليل
لاثار القصف الذي استهدف ابنيه سكنيه على
ما يبدو
في العاصمه السوريه دمشق
وقد ظهرت في هذه الصور اضرار جسيمه جراء
هذه الغارات
تضاف هذه الاضرار الى الخسائر البشريه
الكبيره كما ذكرت وسائل اعلان خسائر بشريه
بين قتلى وجرحى وواضح عنف هذه الغارات
وتركز هذه الغارات في قلب العاصمه السوريه
دمشق
[موسيقى]
في حال ورود اي تطورات او معلومات اضافيه
بشان ما استهدفه القصف الاسرائيلي في
العاصمه السوريه
دمشق سنعود بطبيعه الحال للمتابعه
[موسيقى]